missed 11 nominations eight of them
tonight oh my god
i'm very excited i'm very very excited i
have nothing prepared uh so i'm also
terrified
but it is what it is you gotta do what
you gotta do you got your album but then
you're also nominated for little nazix's
album
yeah what what is he gonna do tonight um
i don't know and he still texts me stuff
but he doesn't text me enough like i
don't know what he's about to do tonight
but i just know it's going to be great i
saw him walking down here in just a robe
and literally just the road
yeah as he should
you know the thing that we love so much
about the grammy's dosia is the
collaborations those moments that we
don't see coming on your bucket list of
people you want to work with who is
who's that still out there that you're
you're like come on i want to work with
well everybody knows it's nikki it's all
the time it's nikki but
there's yeah i don't know i mean there's
new artists too that i probably want to
work with later douchey is another
amazing she's actually here
but dochi is another female rapper who's
incredible and she just signed with tde
and i'm
obsessed i got a little nervous now but
you're heading out on tour after this
with the weekend so that'll be great
you will be going out on tour correct
yes i will yes what he's trying to say
is tell everybody here it's gonna happen
yes north america i'm coming
what are you trying to say is you had
twitter ablaze you had social media
blades you had our newsroom ablaze with
the news that dosiagra is putting music
that can't happen
uh
you're too good to stop it
come
we're here at the grammys it's a great
time and i'm so happy to be here and
thank you guys so much so you don't have
anything planned for tonight like no
nothing in your head you didn't sit
right now okay but that's okay sometimes
i think that that's fine you know it
works it works for people so it should
work for me i hope yeah um yeah and tell
me about this look and if your waist is
really that small in real life it's not
an illusion okay i'm like tell her talk
about illusion
everything's fake it's amazing so tell
me about this from head to toe this is
versace this is um
something that we sketched out for the
last couple months and i wanted
something simple and i wanted to go edgy
with the hair and have fun and that's
basically it lots of tatas it's
delicious it's because i'm feeling like
all of these were hand put on
every single entire one and i asked that
question the other night and i was like
there's just no way i don't understand
so i think it's like a team of 30 people
that sit there and just with each piece
of fabric just wow go in together and
and yeah pray to god
it's amazing by the way who's your best
friend
uh sweetie
she's a real bad [ __ ] and me too and me
too i thank you no my wife and her best
friend literally
perform this every time they see each
other what does it mean to you in every
anywhere they see each other the woman
duo of friends doesn't do that like we
all that's all our anthem you should i
performed a lot of songs that aren't
mine many times and uh yeah not on
camera but that's good yeah
it's important have a great time
good luck tonight good luck with this
necklace real quick before you leave i
can't i can't i can't i can't how many
carrots are we are we doing tonight lots
of carrots earrings too
earrings some carrots on there as well